[Musik]
welchen platz hat der islam in
westlichen gesellschaften in österreich
ist diese frage rechtlich schon seit
über 100 jahren geklärt
gesellschaftlich aber wird die
diskussion heftiger geführt denn je
ganz ähnlich wie bei uns in der schweiz
das neue islam gesetz in österreich
verspricht lösungen und schafft neue
probleme
deshalb ist heute für die tat ist bei
mir zu gast er ist
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität salzburg herzlich willkommen
qualitativ auslösen dann zu hören war
für die toffees ein punkt in diesem
neuen islam gesetz sieht vor dass die
muslimischen gemeinschaften ein
positives verhältnis zu staat und
gesellschaft anerkennen müssen
bei uns in der schweiz wird zurzeit eine
heftige debatte geführt über kulturelle
aspekte ob beispielsweise das hand
reichen gehirnschlag etwas ist das vor
die gesetzlich durchgesetzt werden muss
gibt es diese debatte ist reich auch
also es gibt keine debatte über eine
gesetzliche grundlage
und sie wird auch nicht national geführt
aber es gibt durchaus immer wieder
kleinere debatten hier und da in schulen
und dementsprechend den verschiedenen
bundesländern wo das passiert dass man
das sozusagen probleme macht ich glaube
das hat irgendwo ein bisschen mit zum
einen damit zu tun dass es ein
missverständnis gibt im hinblick auf
unterschiedliche konzepte für sexualität
körperlichkeit und es nicht klar ist was
man eigentlich damit meint auf der
anderen seite hat das auch damit zu tun
dass wir in österreich vermutlich ein
sehr homogenes gesellschaftsbild
vertreten dass dieses unterschiedliche
verständnis gibt es denn eine seite die
sich da durchzusetzen hat das ist ja
eigentlich die grundlage der ganzen
kontroverse und das geht auch in
richtung autoritären gesellschaften und
gesellschaftsmodelle und das ist glaube
ich der springende punkt also wird von
uns mit pluralität pluralismus in
wirklichkeit eher in der realität etwas
schwer und ich spreche von einem reinen
beispiel eine anekdote
die ich selbst erlebt habe ich war zu
besuch in serie in den vereinigten
staaten von amerika und hatte dort eine
führung erhalten in einem islamischen
montessori kindergarten und die dame die
mir die führung gemacht hatte war eine
frau die einen gesichtsschleier getragen
hatte und ich muss ehrlich gestehen
das liegt jetzt schon viele jahre zurück
aber ich habe mir zu diesem zeitpunkt
die frage gestellt wie kann es sein dass
ich selbst hier vorteile habe will ich
frauen die einen gesichtsschleier tragen
nie so wahrgenommen habe
dass sie quasi aktive teile der
gesellschaft sind das war ihr verurteilt
dass das war mein vorteil obwohl ich
sozusagen mit muslimen ja auch zu tun
habe und mich auskenne und hat mir dann
die frage stellt was bedeutet das was
sagt das denn nicht aus über uns unsere
europäischen kontinental europäischen
gesellschaften also wir entwerfen auf
den gesellschaftsbild wo alles nach
einer leitkultur zu gehen hat wenn wir
denn diesen begriff der aus deutschland
stammt dazu verwenden aber wir sind
nicht sehr offen unterschiedliche
lebensmodelle anzuerkennen
egal ob man das jetzt positiv oder
negativ findet aber sozusagen
anzuerkennen dass der andere anders ist
das beispiel zeigt aber aus meiner sicht
auch noch etwas das es diese diese
unsicherheiten offenbar inzwischen
geschlechtlichen umgang untereinander
eben auch ganz stark unter den muslimen
selbst gibt also dass vielleicht die
diskussion gar nicht so sehr auf vision
muslimen und nicht muslimen geführt wird
als vielmehr auch in wien setzt man es
wäre die frage zu stellen was der
hintergrund ist wenn zum beispiel die
vereinigten staaten von amerika
gesellschaftlich gesehen oft frauen den
einkauf tagen es ermöglichen hinter
einer mcdonalds theke zu stehen und
einen burger zu verkaufen das aber
sozusagen in der schweiz oder in
österreich in deutschland nicht denkbar
ist
bedeutet das ja auch etwas sozusagen wie
man menschen erlaubt teil einer
gesellschaft sein zu können
und ich glaube auch da haben wir
scheinbar komplett unterschiedliche
zugänge die sozusagen für die einen auch
räume eröffnen und ermöglichen
was in anderen gesellschaften gar nicht
fähig ist und dass reproduziert
natürlich bestimmte bilder die in
unseren köpfen sind etwa dass ich selbst
das bild hatte muslimische frauen die
einen gesichtsschleier tragen
gesellschaftlich nicht partizipieren
lassen wir uns gleich bei der
gesellschaftlichen partizipation leiden
und über dieses neue ich sage das jetzt
in österreich sprechen
dieses neue gesetz voraus es gibt ein
altes gesetz was war denn jetzt genau
der grund dass man ein vorhandenes
gesetz erneuert
schließlich ist das was man beabsichtigt
hatte ursprünglich eine novellierung zu
der es nicht gekommen ist das ist zu
einem vollständig neuen gesetz gekommen
war eigentlich ursprünglich eine idee
der islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft in
österreich die ja seit 1979 eine von
heute 16 anerkannten
religionsgesellschaften darstellt
österreich kennt ein system der herr
einnehmenden neutralität und säkularität
das heißt es gibt natürlich eine
trennung zwischen staat und kirche im
machtpolitischen sinne aber es gibt
gleichzeitig felder der kooperation
sozusagen sogenannte gemeinsame anliegen
wie etwa nehmen wir den
religionsunterricht an öffentlichen
schulen oder dergleichen wo es zu
kooperationen zwischen staatlichen
behörden und anerkannten kirchen und
religionsgesellschaften gewusst und
trägt ist beispielsweise auch in diesem
gesetz
der ist nicht im gesetz geregelt aber
der ist grundsätzlich im
österreichischen religionsrecht geregelt
und weil er da geregelt ist genießen
alle anerkannten kirchen und
gesellschaften und
religionsgesellschaften mit ausnahme der
zeugen jehova dieses recht was aber sehr
wichtig ist es dass das gesetz von 1912
bei weitem nicht mehr die band den
bedürfnissen der muslime nachgekommen
ist wo sich die situation natürlich
völlig verändert hat
habsburger monarchie waren die muslime
mehrheitlich in bosnien und herzegowina
und heute sind die muslime mehr als die
protestanten
lassen sie uns das schnell für unser
schweizerisches publikum vor allem auch
da legen weil wir wenig kenntnis haben
über diese diesen teil der
österreichischen geschichte und wie die
muslime ihre öffentlich-rechtliche
anerkennung bereits 1912 erlangt haben
wie kam das die anerkennung kam damit
das ist in der habsburgermonarchie
bereits ein anerkennungsgesetz gegeben
hat für kirchen und
religionsgesellschaften mann ist ende
des 19 jahrhunderts übergegangen von
einem eher staats- kirchen- system wo
sozusagen der staat bestimmt wirklichen
strukturiert sind hin zu einer
anerkennung von pluralität das heißt es
wurden die protestanten die jüdische
gemeinschaft und andere kleinere kirchen
und religionsgesellschaften anerkannt
gesetzlich damit hat man diese
pluralität eine rechtliche grundlage
gegeben und das ist weitergeführt worden
und ist auch übergegangen in ein
neutrales verhältnis man spricht in
österreich von der man kann religion
rechtlich von einem konkordanzsystem
sprechen wo sozusagen auch die kirchen
und religionsgesellschaften heute quasi
als sozialpartner anerkannt werden
sprich sie haben auch die möglichkeit
bei angelegenheiten die sie betreffen
wie etwa ein religions- sondergesetz
dass sie dann auch mitspracherecht haben
das heißt es wird nicht über siege
herrscht sondern es ist in einem
partnerschaftlichen verhältnis wird über
gemeinsame angelegenheiten gesprochen
das erklärt dann auch warum die
initiative für ein neues gesetz seiten
der muslime kann man nicht reiten ist
der staat ja wobei natürlich man muss
das sagen während die islamische
glaubensgemeinschaft 2003 das erste mal
zu einer forderung aus laut
ausgesprochen hat ist es erst 2011 zu
einer diskussion gekommen und das hat im
wesentlichen mit einer veränderung
innerhalb des österreichischen
politischen systems zu tun nämlich
dahingehend dass das erste mal in der
geschichte des landes ein sogenanntes
integrationsstaatssekretariat damals
noch im innenministerium gegründet wurde
das heute teil des außenministeriums ist
nämlich wir sprechen vom
bundesministerium für äußere
angelegenheiten und integration
das heißt es gab eine aufwertung der
integrationsagenden und hier hat diese
integrationsagenden lagen und liegen
heute auch noch in den händen des
heutigen außenministers der aus der
christdemokratie kommt der hat sich
dieses diesem thema gewidmet vermutlich
jetzt auch partei strategisch aus
folgender perspektive dass nämlich die
freiheitliche partei österreichs die ja
eine rechtspopulistische partei ist
ähnlich der svp hier in der schweiz im
wesentlichen die islam agenten über ein
monopol auf den islam agentin hatte die
aber sehr negativ behandelt hatte
klarerweise also aufgrund auch eines
gewissen rassistischen fremming die
christdemokratie hat hier versucht in
eine position darzustellen und diese
agenten wegzunehmen und da kann es zu
einem gemischten einer gemischten
strategie auf der einen seite eine
anerkennung von pluralität weil man
signalisierte auch mit einer
novellierung oder einem neuen gesetz
dass man sozusagen sich um die
angelegenheiten dieser minderheit
kümmert es ist ein positiver ein
positiver zugang gebaut aber irgendwo
auch mit einer tradition innerhalb der
christdemokratie doch irgendwo eine law
and order partei zu sein und damit
sozusagen auch sozusagen etwas
autoritäre töne auch gleichzeitig
spielen zu lassen und diese dieses
gemisch hat dann irgendwann irgendwo
auch dann die grundlage für dieses neue
islam gesetzt 2015 und ohne dass ich
ihnen jetzt eine gewisse haltung
sozusagen in den mund legen möchte
schwierig aber doch dass da eine gewisse
kritik in bezug auf das gesetz auch von
ihrer seite vorhanden ich war auch einer
der ton an den führenden kritiker würde
ich sagen
neben vielen anderen aber ich mich
bringt vielleicht mit einer mit einer
zahl zum ausdruck wir hatten im jahre
2012 das israeliten gesetzt dass
novelliert wurde und hier kam es
innerhalb der begutachtungsfrist nachdem
der entwurf präsentiert wurde
man hat fünf bis acht wochen zeit hier
ein gutachten zu verfassen
da gab es zehn gutachten von denen neun
formelle gutachten waren und eines war
ein kritisches gutachten einer liberalen
jüdischen community innerhalb des
politischen kultusgemeinde
wenn es lahm gesetzt hatten wir 160
gutachten das ist an und für sich etwas
außergewöhnliches man mehrheitlich auch
sehr negativ ausgefallen
fundamental kritisch gegenüber dem
gesetz und daran führende stimmen allen
voran die österreichischen
religionsrecht ller also die auch sehr
bekannt sind in ihrem in ihrem feld und
darüber hinaus noch weiter andere
kirchen und angeles vor allem von der
muslimischen seite die hier
dieses gesetz kritisiert haben lassen
sie uns mal ganz konkret werden die
muslime selbst haben 2003 wie sie gesagt
haben eigentlich so eine erneuerung des
gesetzes angestrebt jetzt ist man
trotzdem nicht zufrieden was hinter
jetzt strittigen punkt enden gesetzt die
strittigen punkte
das erste würde ich mal beginnen noch
nicht einmal beim gesetzestext sondern
die frage wie der gesetzestext zustande
gekommen ist also wie ich vor bereits
gesagt habe an und für sich gibt es in
österreich dieses konkordanzsystem das
heißt die politische kultur der
kooperation in dem fall zwischen staat
und kirche ist in wirklichkeit seit 1945
war das ungebrochen
also es gibt eine grundregel die heißt
es wird kein gesetz verabschiedet gegen
den willen einer anerkannten kirche oder
religionsgesellschaft sondern es wird
immer in kooperation einfühlung name
ausverhandelt und genau das ist ein heer
das ist hier nicht es kommt auf die
perspektive an manche meinen es ist
passiert dahingehend dass die vertreter
der glaubensgemeinschaft ihr okay
gegeben haben das stimmt auch teilweise
andererseits ist es dahingehend nicht
passiert weil die glaubensgemeinschaft
einen eine 30-seitige kritik auch damals
als gutachten eingereicht hatte und
diese kritik nicht berücksichtigt wurde
mehrheitlich also es gab zwar ein paar
gute veränderungen auch aber
mehrheitlich wurde wurden die meisten
dinge ignoriert und das bedeutet bereits
darauf hin dass das diese kooperative
haltung eben hier nicht der fall war
das heißt in der politischen kultur der
kooperation in dem fall konkret zwischen
der islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft und
den staatlichen behörden gab es keine
kooperation und das ist ein
doch in wirklichkeit also sie meinen
wenn der weg zum gesetz schon schlecht
ist dann kann daraus kein gutes gesetz
erwachsen wie ja beziehungsweise nicht
auf kooperatives freundschaftliche
haltung nun gut jetzt ist das gesetz
seit märz 2015 in kraft und wird jetzt
umgesetzt und jetzt wird mich
interessieren was sind denn jetzt
bereits die folgen des gesetzes ganz
fehle die die umstrukturierung der
islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft händen
es sind ja an und für sich zwei davon
betroffenen konkret die islamische
glaubensgemeinschaft die 2013 anerkannt
ist und die 1979 anerkannte islamische
glaubensgemeinschaft müssen wir noch
schnell klären
die alevitische glaubensgemeinschaft ist
inkludiert in das islam gesetzt
das ist auch rein und ein problem aus
der perspektive von film religionsrecht
land dahingehend weil die anerkennung
der islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft
nicht auf basis des islam gesetzes
passierte sondern auf basis des
anerkennungsgesetz von 18 67 sowie das
auch für viele andere möglich wäre
und da war auch die frage warum nimmt
man jetzt sozusagen dieser sehr kleine
gruppe auch die erwiderungen opposition
zu einer größeren alevitischen alt
alevitischen tradition steht warum nimmt
man die hinein die haben sich natürlich
gefreut weil sie waren seit kurzem erst
anerkannt und sind in den genuss vieler
rechte damit gekommen
auf der anderen seite hatte es aber
geheißen ja wie geht das
dass man die hinein nimmt wenn die
islamische glaubensgemeinschaft in ihrem
selbstverständnis die aleviten nicht als
teil von sich selbst sieht aber mit
verlaub das ist wohl nicht der
strittigste punkt des gesetzes das nicht
der strittigste punkt aber das ist so
hat eine symbolische bedeutung
strittigste punkt es gibt einige punkte
aber um das vielleicht also das am
meisten diskutierte er war sicherlich
das sogenannte auslands finanzierungs
verboten man hat das im gesetz er kann
als positiv formulieren inland inlands
finanzierungs gebot
aber es geht im wesentlichen darum dass
und das entspricht in wirklichkeit an
der strategie von vielen europäischen
nationalstaaten man versucht die
innenministerin versuchen so etwas wie
einen österreichischen deutschen
französischen islam zu kreieren
dagegen etwas einzuwenden kommt drauf an
was man darunter versteht also das ist
ja stehen die darunter na ja es ist
natürlich eine wiederum eine längere
andere debatte also jemand mit einem
historischen gedächtnis würde sagen da
gibt es ein paar kritische punkte nehmen
wir zum beispiel jetzt der die
geschichte deutschlands da gibt es eine
auch eine gute studie dazu wo gezeigt
wurde dass diese dieser formulierung des
europäischen islams damals schon von den
kolonialmächten würden zwei deutschen
kolonie kongressen 19 10 und zweiter
fällt mir nicht ein wanderer genau war
man auch von einer europäisierung des
islams gesprochen hat und darunter hat
man verstanden sozusagen eine
zivilisierung des islams eine
kultivierung des islams damit er
sozusagen weil er fremd ist besser
hinein passt also das heißt einige
wieder aversion gegen diesen begriff
gegen das historische gedächtnis
natürlich wir wenn wir uns das anschauen
in den debatten verwenden viele
unterschiedliche akteure diesen begriff
mit ganz unterschiedlichen bedeutungen
halten wir haben den passanten euro
islam wir haben den tag ramadan mit
islam european islam wir haben die
europäischen immer konferenzen mit islam
europäischer prägung hört sich alles
sehr ähnlich an meinen aber alle ganz
unterschiedliche dinge
deswegen würde ich auch sagen dass er
ein politikum wo man genauer hinschauen
muss aber ganz grundsätzlich was spricht
dagegen dass ein staat mit spricht
darüber wie muslimen und islam
innerhalb der eigenen grenzen definiert
und gestaltet wird das machen ja selbst
muslimische staaten wir haben in der
türkei eine ganz eigene islam bakterien
wir haben in saudi arabien in pakistan
gesetzgebungen gegen islam letztlich
auch definieren warum sollte das gerade
in österreich im europäischen nationen
haben das sei absolut richtig und ich
glaube das ist auch der springende punkt
ich hoffe nicht dass sich unsere
europäischen demokratien quasi weniger
demokratische und autoritäre staaten als
vorbild nehmen wie kirchenstaats
beziehungen auszusehen haben das ist der
springende punkt und in bezug jetzt auch
auf von einer österreichischen
perspektive ausgesprochen
das österreichische religionsrecht sieht
vor dass eine
jede anerkannte kirchen
religionsgesellschaft eine gewisse
innere autonomie hat in bezug auf eine
eigene angelegenheiten
also sprich die katholische kirche sieht
sich als katholische kirche in
österreich aber als globale kirche
natürlich mit dem vatikan und das
globale kirche die auch global agiert
die frage ist sozusagen nur noch mal
zurückzukommen auf diesen kritikpunkt
der inlands oder finanzierungs gebot
oder des auslands finanzierungs verbots
es geht im wesentlichen darum dass eine
grundlage des österreichischen
religions- rechts basierend auf der
österreichischen verfassung jene ist
dass es einen gleichheitsgrundsatz gibt
das heißt der staat darf nicht
verschiedene kirchen unterschiedlich
behandeln sondern es gilt grundsätzlich
dass alle gleich sind vor dem gesetz
und das stößt natürlich den muslimen
berechtigterweise auf warum dürfen
sozusagen die protestanten und die
mormonen und andere kirchen und
religionsgesellschaften gelder von außen
erhalten auch um personen personalkosten
damit zu decken und die muslime nicht
kann es nicht auch als schon als chance
gewertet werden von muslimischer seite
dass man sich vielleicht endlich einmal
los sagt von einer ausländischen
finanzierung und kreativ wird in einer
eigenen gesellschaft fündig zu werden
und die eigenen maschinen zu finanzieren
das ist sicherlich eine der absichten
auch am stärksten betrifft es ja
tatsächlich die vom türkischen
religionsministerium finanzierten immer
von denen auch schon die ersten zurück
mussten weil sie nicht mehr das visum
erhalten hatten haben
das ist sicherlich ein wichtiger aspekt
der der manchen muslimischen
gemeinschaften auch sicherlich
dahingehend mehr autorität über sich
selbst gibt und der von ihnen aus
positiv gewertet wird mir geht es aber
weniger jetzt um die frage eines in
muslimischen projekte sondern mir geht
es darum wie verhält sich der staat
gegenüber den kirchen und
religionsgesellschaften stellt vor allem
die ungleichbehandlung die
ungleichbehandlung also ich denke wenn
ungleichbehandlung ist nichts was im
jahre 2016 gesetzlich festgeschrieben
werden sollten
das sind interessante aspekte auch vor
dem hintergrund dass das gesetz sei
einerseits die öffentlich-rechtliche
anerkennung der
islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft
gewährleistet was auch beispielsweise
heißt das islamische feiertage unter
staatlichem schutz stehen gerät höfe die
friedhofsmauer sind das ist relativ weit
aus die religionswächter haben
dahingehend argumentiert dass all diese
rechte in wirklichkeit es vor auch schon
gegeben hat sie waren hat nicht
gesetzlich verbrieft aber aufgrund des
verständnisses des österreichischen
religionsrecht hat es das immer schon
gegeben und den zusammenhang jetzt
konkret mit den sogenannten islamischen
feiertagen sind die für das arbeitsrecht
irrelevant das heißt sie haben im
wesentlichen eine symbolische bedeutung
sie können von schülerinnen und schülern
sozusagen in anspruch genommen werden
auch das war in der vergangenheit schon
der fall
und sie können sozusagen dadurch dass
sie rechtlich anerkannt sind kann mit
einem persönlichen verständnis mit dem
arbeitgeber darüber gesprochen werden
aber ein recht darauf wie es etwa bei
einem protestanten der fall ist mit
einem gesetzlich anerkannten feiertag
das ist es nicht und das ist genau der
punkt so zu sagen wo man gesagt hat naja
das ist damit hat man sich geschmückt in
dem gesetz aber das hat nicht wirklich
substanziell etwas verändert das heißt
für sie ist das gesetz nicht im
wesentlichen ein fortschritt sondern hat
symbolcharakter
ja ich denke es ist auch in vielen
punkten ein rückschritt also das ist ja
das ist das problem eher dass ich in den
vordergrund stellen würde
also nehmen wir etwa diesen symbolisch
sehr wichtigen aspekt der des
sogenannten generalverdacht der
kritisiert worden ist also das heißt in
§ 2 über über das im islam gesetz auch
ihre lehren einrichtungen und gebräuche
genießen diesen schutz sofern sie nicht
mit gesetzlichen regelungen im
widerspruch stehen
der kultusminister hat argumentiert dass
diese dieser absatz quasi schon im islam
gesetz 19 12 stand das hatte auch seinen
grund seiner berechtigung nämlich
deswegen weil das eherecht konfessionell
gebunden war und man damals verhindern
wollte dass muslime mit auf basis des
islam gesetzes die polygamie einfordern
nachdem das eherecht heute nicht mehr
konfessionell gebunden ist ist das
glaube ich irrelevant darüber hinaus und
das ist sozusagen das symbolische daran
gilt dieser grundsatz ohnehin im osten
in der österreichischen verfassung steht
aber nur eines
versetzungen keinen anderen religion
sondergesetzen und das ist das was
sozusagen den beigeschmack vermittelt ja
die muslime hätten ja ein problem mit
der verfassung und ihre religion
widerspräche ja irgendwo bestimmten
gesetzlichen rahmenbedingungen und das
ist sozusagen dieser generalverdacht den
man hier mit transportiert der
problematisiert wer zu recht
problematisiert wurde und ein weiterer
aspekt ist der des vereinsrechts so wir
haben mit dem neuen islam gesetz eine
neue regelung wonach muslime sich nicht
mehr religiös organisieren können auf
basis des vereinsgesetzes das heißt das
heißt alle muslime die religiös
körperschaft lich auftreten wollen
müssen innerhalb einer anerkannten
islamischen religionsgesellschaft sich
organisieren
das heißt das vereinsrecht gilt nicht
mehr sobald sie die religiöse lehre auch
verbreiten aber es haben sie nicht auch
ein gewisses verständnis dafür dass der
staat offenbar bemüht ist
ich sage jetzt einer einer extrem großen
in einer islamischen vielfalt auch ein
bisschen eine form zu geben und diese
zurechtzustutzen
wie gesagt ich halte das für etwas
autoritäres also ich denke ich bin
grundsätzlich jetzt auch norbert
normativ werden wir darüber sprechen bin
ich eher ein freund der us des
us-amerikanischen hotels wo religion zum
einen nicht in den staat hinein genommen
wird gleichzeitig aber sehr frei ist ja
also sie würden auch nicht für einen
französisch ist oder wer regieren darf
die komplette trennung von staat und
kirchen oder start und naja ist
institution vor das us-amerikanische ist
eine trennung eine eine säkulare ordnung
aber eine nicht mehr unterdrücken
sondern eine die die freiheit gibt das
österreichische modell ist eines der
kooperation was auch seinen sinn hat ja
irgendwo weil es damit sozusagen immer
auch einen kontakt und einen austausch
gibt und das macht auch irgendwohin
aber das problem hier ist er das
sozusagen die frage der versammlungs und
rheins freiheit quasi für die muslime
ausgehebelt wurde diese sich sozusagen
muslimisch betätigen wollen und das ist
glaube ich ein sehr kritischer aspekt
weil am ende wenn man sich nicht wieder
findet in einer der anerkannten
religionsgesellschaften was bedeutet das
dass ich sozusagen irgendwo dann auch
völlig draußen bin aus dem system und
ein argument das vorgeführt wurde
um das zu unterstützen war jenes dass
man gesagt hat dann macht man eine klare
trennlinie zwischen den extremen
richtungen innerhalb des islams und
jenen die sich sozusagen innerhalb der
islamischen glaubensgemeinschaft dieser
innerhalb dieser einordnen und damit
auch eine positive grundhaltung zum
start haben aber auch hier würde ich
meinen ist das irgendwo problematisch
weil es bedeutet im endeffekt dass jene
extremere gesinnungen dann irgendwo in
den untergrund geben warum weil sie ja
tatsächlich nicht mehr religiös tätig
sein dürfen und auch das da denke ich
ist das ist es in wirklichkeit dann in
eine andere richtung
sie wurden in österreich geboren sie
haben jahrgang 1981 wenn sie die
entwicklung der muslime in österreich
über die letzten 30 jahre mitverfolgen
was sehen sie da ganz persönlich für sie
was wie hat sich das ganz grundlegend
für sie entwickelt eine entspanntheit
die sind dann 80er 90er angegeben hat
die gegeben hatte die ist gegangen und
würde ich sagen ich denke nach wie vor
dass die die menschen in österreich ja
im wesentlichen als sehr entspannte
leute sind aber ich glaube dass die
politischen diskurse die wir seit mehr
als zehn jahren jetzt in österreich
haben vor allem ausgelöst durch die
rechtspopulisten einiges vergiften und
dass das auch ein widerhall findet bei
einem politischen eliten ich habe
natürlich auch analysen gemacht zu der
zeit vor 2015 und 2025 sehr sehr klar
und deutlich dass die politischen eliten
des alten schlags wenn ich jetzt einmal
sage ein ganz anderes verständnis der
hereinnahme und der
selbstverständlichkeit und der
anerkennung des islams als
das österreichische narrativ auch
irgendwo vertreten haben also bosnien
herzegowina war teil der habsburger
monarchie
damit gab es so etwas wie eine
politische kultur der hereinnahme und
der akzeptanz wir sprechen vor allem die
politische situation an nachvollziehbar
wie eine politikwissenschaftliche frage
aber trotzdem der andere große akteur
ist ja im prinzip die kirche oder sind
die kirchen und da ist doch aber doch
ein gewisses wohlwollen auch spürbar das
heißt wir haben sicher die kritischen
entwicklungen die entspanntheit die ab
die von der mann lag gekommen ist aber
wir haben doch auf der anderen seite ein
wohlwollen von anderen akteuren
was ist denn ihre prognose wie sich das
entwickeln geht welcher trend wird die
oberhand gewinnen oder neutralisieren
also ich träume da jetzt keine
zukunftsprognosen geben zu geben
aber ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass
aufgrund der anerkennung und die er seit
1979 durch die institutionalisieren des
islams dass es eine körperschaft gibt
die agiert im politischen feld
sicherlich einen großen vorteil gibt
gegen war vielen anderen europäischen
ländern einfach deswegen da der staat
hat ansprechpartnerinnen die islamische
glaubensgemeinschaft hin und b man ist
ja auch in zivilgesellschaftlichen
bereich damit aktiv gewesen seitens der
glaubensgemeinschaft das heißt gegenüber
kinder es gibt dann sehr kooperatives
verhältnis zu den anderen anerkannten
kirchen und religionsgesellschaften aber
es ist auch so dass das man mit anderen
zivilgesellschaftlichen akteuren immer
wieder auftritt ich sag das jetzt im
unterschied zu etwa zu deutschland in
deutschland wurst eben diese anerkennung
nicht gibt gibt es eine starke
kriminalisierung von vielen muslimischen
vereinigungen die immer wieder im
verfassungsschutzbericht stehen etc
das ist eine neue diskussion und die
werden wir an anderer stelle
wahrscheinlich weiterführen die
öffentlich-rechtliche anerkennung allein
führt nicht zur abnahme der
gesellschaftlichen debatte die wir
weiter geführt ganz herzlichen dank
ihnen dass sie da war ich danke für die
anderen und richtig warum ist sex
politisch die britisch ergebnisse
wissenschaftlerin chilli nike hat über
das geschlechterverhältnis in arabischen
ländern geforscht
in der nun folgenden sternstunde
philosophie erklärt sie warum politische
umwälzungen nur stattfinden können und
ein umdenken in den becken beginnt
[Musik]